let's continue with with the second part
of those of those talk thank you Norm so
thank you for continuing with us
so now that we know what our unit games
and all of the sound stuff we can forget
all about it focus on two to one game
then
start doing actually some boil analysis
well in a few minutes
so let's recall this conventional wisdom
so we want to find a code
the following positive
ready to be complete
the sound
so right now we're talking about two to
one games
so we want the code to have the testers
okay so we want the code and the Tesla
so we want the tester to make something
which is a two to one check
so we want
do we do query
it's a good one test
to do this let's let's say that
finally we're disconnecting about the
blow up
we want the code to be not too small
capital M
one C to be at least polynomial in the
dimension
so this is exactly the convey
right
you want to be large
so this is the conversion of wisdom this
is the blackheads we are in the slide
and right now I'm trying going to try to
convince you that if you're willing to
let one of this slide let's say that
your way to give up this condition for
then actually coming up with a code is
not that hard and it's been known for I
don't know 10 years or more than that
so
I'm going to describe to your code in
the text I'm not going to prove it that
satisfies everything except for four
and this is what is called the wrong
code
so in this setting the alphabet Sigma is
some large finite field fq
think of Q as constant but you know is a
large ones but per million or something
is going to be only dictators
so for example six of all of the strings
which are evaluations or functions
m
the function f is a dictator
so yeah
that's right let's take this processing
so this is what he's often refer to so
good
so I claim that this test is good okay
now I need to tell you what destiny
this is what is called noise testo
hold out let's say that we have some
small parameter Epsilon
now the tester positives for us
example
point x uniformly
sample Y which is one reception call it
BMX
I'm using Norm Rotation by that I mean
that I keep each coordinate as is with
481 reception and otherwise the example
is from fq uniformly and independently
so I collected these two points and now
I'm going to evaluate my function f on
two of them and ask whether the value
changed or not
foreign
this is the tester this is the noise
tester it's as it's simple as it gets
now let's think about it
if my function f is indeed from the
alarm code
if f of x is this x i then I claim that
the tester passes with probability at
least one reception
this is because the probability that
they kept calling it I implies is one
reception in which case the test accepts
so this is simple the test is complete
well it doesn't
soundness or Sonos is more tricky
but it's not too difficult so you can
prove
so you want to do folding if you're
actually doing PCP but if you just want
to do a tester then it's good enough
but the issue with folding is that you
just want to avoid constant functions
but uh
let's let it slide let's say that the
function is balanced
so okay because your value is annoying
but I'm going to need to write exclaim
so suppose
you know
that's a bit
which enough skill the probability that
is equal to a
1 over Q
I'm going to say that this is balanced
however thank you I'm just yeah so
suppose we have such function
then if this function passes the test
we've noticed a probability
you should think of that as something
small but much larger than one over Q
like I don't know one over Q to the 0.1
or something
then the only way that this can happen
is if F resembles a dictator in some
sense
so this variable whose influence is loud
so this is what so we said correlation
for example Theory correlation but this
is good enough for applications
so the wrong code seems good
it is complete it is sound
it is took away right we only made two
queries and it's Unique it's even a
quality like it doesn't get any simple
but not
the only thing that failed this for
so if you look at the left of the world
you can skew to them
the number of codewords that you have
is little n
which is a
right
this is
foreign
but it really kills everything we cannot
we don't know how to use the long code
to prove or anything remotely close to
it
well we're going to go into the program
so okay so we see that it's easy to find
a code that satisfies one two and three
but we want four
so long code is something that is very
exposed so let's go on the other end and
look at the code which is much less
parcel energy is four but then we're
going to lose
don't speak together
this is
so what is the other marker
now we are going to look at the truth
tables
branches from F2 today
to F2 and the functions are going to be
the characters or the linear functions
so so this is the other mod code and
actually in the first hour we already
saw a local test though for the other
one
remind us of desktop so you pick X and Y
only
then you check the title of x
but f of x plus one
so this test is complete we already saw
that it has satisfied subduction of
soundness which is not bad
you can observe it four holes so this is
just a computation
but
this tester makes three queries and not
two
which is not good so we don't know how
to use it for two to one or for uni
games and in fact you can
easily see that this code is not going
to have any two quality test or
because for any two X and Y a little
different if you choose a random linear
function the values of f of x and F of Y
are going to be independent bits
so there is not going to be any check
that you can perform in them to
distinguish something linear and
something which is not linear
so you really need to have a frequency
so now we have two solutions each one of
them fails miserably for different
reasons
and you see that there is an extension
between you know having enough codewords
versus having a test which is
you know strong enough to be unique
I'm not sure
that's how low can you go on this phone
before people don't see anything
foreign
[Music]
basically
start with the hardware code
and try to force it to have a two
polyester
so if you look at the hardware what you
have is you have a linear function and
you spell out the values of this
function on all of the points of the
space
but you might as well also specify the
restrictions of f to South bases and
stuff like that which give you more
information so because it's more
information maybe you can do smarter
tests and this is precisely what the
government code is
yeah let's go
foreign
capital F sub s
it's going to map
what I'm going to denote by glass of NL
F2 to there
so this is my notation for
subspaces of Dimension L of F2 to the n
so to each Subspace it's going to assign
some linear function on it
and I'm going to identify linear
functions with some Vector that
specifies it so I'm going to think of
the output as some Vector in f 2 to the
f
so how does big sub coding go well it
goes in the most natural way
first of all we look at s we look at the
corresponding card about code
first have little efforts
that's linear function corresponding to
s
and then this Capital FS is just going
to be the Restriction of FS to a
Subspace
foreign
games
so this is a code now we need to tell
you what the tester is
so that's so
so once again we have some assignment
gives to each start space linear
function
and we want to test whether this
assignment is a Glassman code word named
if it arrives from some Global linear
function
oh if it's far from each one of these
yes so do you also have some embedding
of these subspaces like like you have
you're identifying them with electricity
so I identify the linear functional
error with respect to the error
so you can think of like some fixed
identification yeah it's not really it
doesn't really matter just
just that I can write something here
which is
so
so we'll be labeling that to each
subface gives something a function and
we want to test whether it comes from
one you know Global linear function
really when you think about it for five
minutes there is really only one thing
you can do
what you do is sample
the intersect in a very large dimension
each one of them as dimensional and I
want them to intersect on the loudest
possible Dimension namely L minus one
foreign
okay
so this is the test now we are going to
start analyzing its properties
so one thing is clear
the tester is complete
if I run it on an actual codeword from
the government code it's going to access
to probability one
secondly it is clear that well you can
just calculate
the length of the code audio
so if you calculate the number of
subspaces of Dimension L is actually due
to the L times n
and the number of words that I have is 2
to the n
so they are polynomial related as long
as L is constant and it is going to be
constant so we have the property before
going for us the blob is not too much
foreign
ties
we need the tester to actually be a
two-point test though well it is to
quite extra and we need it to be two to
one another two to two
and it is because
let's say that I tell you what is the
value of FL
then for the tester to pass you must
assign FL Prime to be this specific
function on one dimensional
then there is only going to be one
extension to helpline
so right so if I tell you what is the
assignment 12
then I've told you what is the
assignment to this part of the time and
you only have one more dimension in the
prime which can either be zero one so
there are two options
so we only need to pull soundness and
then we're done with this lecture but
this is where you know likes become
complicated
foreign
so this is really well all of the fun
starts
it's actually when we started thinking
about these things we thought that well
the test is going to surely be sound
like all tested Dodge with a reasonable
of sound and therefore we are going to
finish and
then you formulate a statement
let me try to put
this is going to be false I'm going to
write something false just you know for
storytelling
so what would you expect
you will expect that if you have an
assignment if that passes this text with
noticeable probability
then it must be because it's correlated
with something global
foreign
you would expect
there to be linear functional
that's that
capital f I believe on a lot of
suspensions
so this is the most hopeful statement
you can come up with and you can try to
prove it but you'll not succeed because
it just Falls
and if you remember in the first hour we
said it
test for the test to be sound it must be
the case that the underlying graph is a
small expander
so actually right now we're going to
construct the test graph this is called
going to be called the government we're
going to show that it's not as muscle
expandable
foreign
because we specified the first very
clearly here
so the vertices of the graph
all of the elementary subspaces
the edges well there is an edge between
LL Prime if the intersecting Dimension
elements
so this is the test graph that
corresponds to this test term
so in order to show you this technique
this false it suffices more for me to
show that this graph is not a small
selection
so
I'm actually going to show you two
examples
one of them is going to be very similar
to all of these dictatorship stuff that
we've seen and we've also seen in Max
stock
domains
this is just one set in the graph that
it's small and doesn't expand very well
it possesses forums
some vector
you have to do that which is not double
zero
and consider all of the surfaces that
contain X
foreign
let's look at the size of this set
as well as the edge expansion of it
so if you look at the measure of the X
you'll see that it is roughly equal to
2 to the L minus 10.
smaller so I should mention here that
whenever we think about the government
off we're going to think of L as some
large constant and L is much larger than
l
so this measure is just slipped off one
but on the other end we can consider the
edge expansion of ZX
let's think about it
if we have L inside ZX it means that the
point x is somewhere in there
and now we take a step in the Gulf
namely we move to a prime which
intersects l in dimension one less
so it's going to be some airplane like
that
so because they intersect in dimension n
minus one
they share half of the vectors and the
probability that X is one of the shared
ones is just half
so when you do a lot of this computation
you can pull the where the expansion is
roughly hard like half maybe plus little
of one
and this immediately shows you that this
stuff is not a small Suboxone though
so I should say that this type of
examples
exist in essentially I think all of the
domains that we discussed so far in this
Workshop
play dictatorship because everything
depends on whether X is inside it or not
so we've seen this type of stuff in Max
stock also in non-stock when you talked
about SM and well a specific element is
mapped to
um but the situation in the cosmograph
is a bit more complicated than that
so actually there is yet another type of
non-explanic sets which we have to think
about
and again for historical Reasons I'm
going to refer to it as zoom out
foreign
[Music]
just a quick question the plus the low
of one is because L Prime might be true
isn't the same as l
yeah no it's because we always shown as
the old vector
doesn't come
into the minus that One Direction
dual cell and then insist that the Dual
could change somebody
this is one way to think about it in
other ways as I'm going to State as a
hyperplanes
so take a hyperplane
and consider the set ZW
which is all of the subspaces
that are inside of it
then again you can compute the measure
of ZW
so you know generating Subspace
dimensional is kind of like generating
early independent vectors W contains
half of the vectors so probably each one
of them is inside WWE is half so after
you get total minor sale
very small
and once again when you look at the edge
expansion you can do similar
calculations to before and observe the
dead expansion is again roughly enough
foreign
relative to what so I want L to be large
but when you think of early percentage
to n it's it's like small yeah
so both of them are loud but n is like
so you should think of L as being very
loud
and N is like two to the two to two or
twelve or something
um yeah and you need to take care to be
sufficient loud perspective Epsilon so
there are many quantifiers over them
another one
so we started with this optimistic
statement
from last time we know that if we want
this element to be took the darkness
panel then we showed it is not supposed
to responder therefore understand the
response this is a very convoluted way
saying that statement is false let's you
know collect together everything that we
saw and just you know try to spell out
an example to refuse the statement and
I'm going to do just combine the
pictures that we solved with these sets
number two
we know that it's smarter they don't
expanders exists so just pick a bunch of
them to cover go to vertices
zx1
I don't know it's do a bunch of sets
if you remember from the slides now for
each one of these parts we are going to
choose completely different linear
function
and this is going to be our assignment
this is the counter example that refutes
the statement
and
this one to say okay the code the test
that we have is not sound it's not ever
going to be sound
but maybe we can relax the notion of
soundness
to be you know this maybe this is the
best you can expect
so there are two questions
this
only type
counter example
foreign
that would be an interesting question on
its own
but it wouldn't be relevant to PCB
whatsoever as long as we hold this
conventional wisdom
so the second question is
so I'm going to shortly formulate
statement which captures a but the
second question is
does this type of soundness
it's a possible I've seen order to
construct a PCP
foreign
and the short version is that dancer is
yes to both of them
and the longer answer is that I'm not
really going to discuss this point
anymore maybe tomorrow you will see how
it goes
because to do that
you have to dway into this you know PCB
constructions and start with level cover
the power petition nobody has time for
that now
instead we're going to think about this
question we're going to try to formulate
the size statement that captures it and
then say how this relates to this notion
of global connectivity and in fact kind
of motivates it
so now I want to format a statement
which fixes this one and takes this type
of examples into account
notes this recipe is general like
whatever small says they don't expect to
give me I can give you an example
we saw two types of examples this zoom
in Zoom outs
but you can actually combine them to get
new examples
for example you can take it to
intersection of those to zoom ins you
can show that it is still small and
still has expansion which is bounded
away from one
in fact you can take intersections of
constantly many of these constantly many
of these you can go why will be wild
with it it's still for this is an
example
and this is all that we know to do and
if you want to form a little statement
like that you have to take by five this
is the only thing that exists
no this is longer no longer a statement
it was it is true so
foreign
functions
it passes the government test with
probability Epsilon
and so first of all I want to say that
the exists some small set it doesn't
expand and secondly I want to say that
on that small set
I have some actual linear function which
is global
so if something like that then there
exists
aspects X and
starts with w both inside F2 to the N
the dimension of X is not too loud
the core dimension of w is not too loud
I have this two sets with X and W and I
have a linear function
if I look at the small set that doesn't
expand it corresponds to X and W which
is all of the suspects that contain X
in a containing w
then on that set I do have a Global
Construction
good question
[Music]
thank you
you need a little bit of physiology
respect to absolutely
yeah but you should think of how is so
Ali is actually going to be log 1 over
Epsilon should we care about
no no but I want it to go everywhere
loud enough so
you're trying to play parameters yeah
anyway so this is the statement and this
is true and in some sense this is the
best thing you can hope for in light of
this picture
yeah good
yeah
must satisfy my promises
remark
so this theorem only tells you gives you
one small set
but in fact you can see that once you
have one small set you can find many
you can eat already statement yeah sense
so let's say that I invoke this
statement I find my small set then I
look at it and I erase it
only what you can do is just randomize
assignments then you can find a new set
using Ethiopian a new set and this way
you're going to find many sets that
cover a lot of the space so well bye
hey man
and
I'm
fine and
what w i that cover
at least on my Galaxy on
this is actually important you need it
if you want to use if you want to
analyze anything
okay
so this is the theorem that we're after
but this film is you know fairly
complicated so multiple reasons uh
first of all the main object in this
film is an assignment to develop access
by some vectors this is something fairly
hard we want something simpler like
maybe you can reduce the steering to
Boolean functions over the vertices that
would be nicer to be simpler
and besides that you know there are many
things floating around you this is
unavoidable in a sense
so the next question that you are going
to ask yourself is is there some simple
statement about where functions which is
equivalent to it
and it turns out that there is one and
for that I'm going to Define
pseudonymous of sets which is along the
lines that Max defined earlier
operation
so we say
instead of vertices
I want to say well s you should think
about the small set and what I want to
say is that the density of s the
relative density in any small cell that
doesn't expand is still very small
so if for every
X
W suspects is
the dimension of x
the core dimension of w
ow
looks that
the density of s
that's it
most Epsilon
foreign
but actually
nowadays we more often call them Global
because you know if you have
some density some X and W well the
density is large this is some local
structure of your set
and if you don't then it means that your
set is global
and what the expansion theorem is going
to say oh so sorry global
so what the expanded theorem is going to
say is that the only sets in the decimal
graph the dev expansion which is small
must be local
government or equivalently
Epsilon greater than zero
there'll be some power
that's good
if s
uh
Delta so the random
and the edge expansion of s
oops
okay so now we have two statements two
theorems that seem to really try to get
at the same type of structure in the gas
tank off they don't both try to say
something about
the structure of non-expanding sets this
theorem is much cleaner you know it's
only three lines this one is
but many more
so this is something that the
kind of more natural to try to prove and
indeed once you study statement at least
you can try to do so for analysis to get
something
well this statement seems unapproachable
for analysis like what are you going to
expand for a basis
and
indeed you can start looking at the
connection between these two statements
and it's an exercise which is not too
difficult to show that
this theorem implies the expanding
theorem
it is fairly easy but the actual thing
that we want is the plan is let's move
this and so that this actually implies
the the heart of your own
and this is true and this is due to
Barack Obama store
so
I have 10 minutes which is enough to
give a rough sketch of these argument
but basically what I'm going to tell you
is
that
this theorem tells you that if you want
to analyze the government first then
it's enough to analyze expansion of the
Dutchman graph and this is something
that you do using four analysis maybe
we'll see a little maybe we'll discuss
some of it tomorrow maybe not we will
see
for the rest of the time unless there
are any questions I'm just going to
sketch this argument because just
because it's very cute
because you can't see it yeah
so just the last line that's not fine
yeah
instructions
is there any way to sort of identify
vertices do some group action Etc to
kind of get some graphs honest SSC from
this which might also suffice
it's a sort of a post question
not
I don't know somehow
this for this stuff the only group
actually they can think of collapses
none of them is going to be some of the
fun
[Applause]
so here the size of the
number for this is called a double
quality is
that you can get through it
is
seven minutes seven minutes
so we are assuming the expanded Theory
when we're going to go next
so we have an assignment traffic depth
we want to find some set of verbs as
using
so how do we do that
now we're going to do something very
important we're going to choose the
linear function randomly
so which is a random linear function and
we are going to look at the subspaces
which the assignment capital F agrees
with this random linear thing that we
sampled
really odd but this is what we're going
to do
there are we have a random set of
vertices and we're going to try to
compute the expected density of it and
the expected Edge expansion and hope for
the best
what is the expected density
well if you play around with this you
can use linearity of expectation and
then
essentially the question boils down to
for fixed l
what is the probability that when I
choose this one can make it less it
agrees with the assignment capital F on
error
and also you just to the minor cell
so the X-ray density is to the minus
level which is very small so it's fine
because what we get
so now what is the edge expansion
well I'm going to try to compute or
estimate the number of edges that stay
inside
so I'm going to write the decision list
so I'm going to arrange over all of the
edges on which the text passes
and I'm going to ask what is the
probability that both endpoints lie
inside
essence
so let's see
so the probability that a is inside SF
is 2 to the minus 0 we already computed
that
now condition on it what is the
probability that time is inside well we
already know that capital F of L Prime
and little f agree on Subspace of f
Prime of Dimension n minus one this is
just spell intersectional Prime
the 21 more dimension
is off so this is to the minor cell
times half
when you calculate it
you see that the number of edges the
expect number of edges that stay inside
that's it
at least to the minus
okay plus one times the number of edges
in which the test passes
which by assumption is at least up to
the function of total number of values
so now we just look at the expected
number of edges stay inside divided by
expected size of SF
second number of edges to stay inside
divided by
d by degree
times expected size
but just plug in all of these
calculations and I see that this is this
ratio is exceptional
foreign
s to do it one of them is the wrong way
and one of them is the right way but I'm
not going to say too much about it you
can conclude that there exist an F where
this ratio is achieved
and when you do one minus that you get
here the edge expansion so you get
this enough well that expansion of SF it
Marks One exceptional
okay so we did all of this a random set
argument and finally we did manage to
get a small set of something that looks
small which has expansion model away
from one
at this point you can apply the
expansion theorem and get that SF is
dance inside some non-expanding set
and if you think about this for a moment
you realize that
it means that inside that non-expandic
set I'll capital F and our letter F
agree on many of the vertices
and this concludes the proof of the
feeling
so yeah so this is a very cute argument
by black Coastal
and it shows you that if you want this
to study this you know completely
looking theorem it's enough to look at
the expansion
so this is all I wanted to say for today
and tomorrow we'll see what to do but
maybe I'm going to talk about the
expansive Theory maybe I'm going to talk
about
some other domains in which you can hope
to get on which you can get something
like that in other applications so
that's it for today thank you let's
think so
[Applause]
thank you
are there any questions follow
yeah
so if you you relax
in this theorem to approximate
agreements if you still use it for DC
get it it's sort of relaxed yeah
what do you mean by approximate
like something
people look under the complete complex
yeah so on a complete complex this makes
sense but here you're dealing with
network correcting code so either you
completely agree or you're doing half of
these things
so this is a very good question
it's an extra question
[Music]
yeah so the final
I see the agreement tester has some
soundness yeah this last thing
um
so there is one exactly one point in the
argument where we use something extra
about the test which is not generic
which is this half
so you know if you have a D2D test then
out of this argument works out but if
the test is nothing to do then it will
work it still seems like generally
speaking there should be a relation
between expansion theorems and human
fuel image but
I'm not familiar with generic a very
generic form of it
and so this this graph this graph is a
regular graph so when I say I'm just
means
um
yeah so the
so this is exactly what Max was asking
so this is this uh
so this is this details applications
okay much of what I said can be extended
to them actually
he's already speaking English
all right so the two here comes because
we're not talking with F2 so each if I
give you a function over the dimension
element so under these two extensions
you know
I don't know which place
I don't know
um
anymore
let's think though again
[Applause]